the Casey DeSantis problem his greatest
asset and his greatest liability
political May 19. Casey DeSantis wife
around DeSantis significant figure in
his political career and often seen as
his greatest asset she's charismatic
telegenic and has a policy portfolio of
Rambo she's a beast in smaller City I
couldn't even believe how powerful she
was unlike Ron unbelievable how she was
in a smaller setting however some view
Casey has both an important advisor and
a political liability she is heavily
involved in decision making leading to a
small inner circle around Ron suggests
she is hesitant to seed power and can be
vindictive leading to conflict with
staff and strategic mistakes now again
this could be a hit piece they're going
after her the truth who knows the role
of Casey descent is a matter of concern
and debate for many with some believing
she humanizes and enhances Ron's image
While others worry about her influence
and the need for a more professional
team around him what are your thoughts
about Casey well first things first uh I
I'm kind of I saw the rundown in the
green room and I saw this article was in
there I was a little bit uncomfortable
because I think wives are
um you know they're out of bounds they
came after my wife she was a
presidential appointee in the DHS but
she wasn't a public figure when they
came after her The Daily Beast all these
scumbags and half po that that's the
easiest way to piss me off
um if you're not a public figure they're
sacred your partner your spouse is
sacred and the only interaction I've had
with her and I want to put this on the
record because I haven't talked about it
anywhere else is when I found out about
her cancer about a year ago on my show
we got like three and a half million
listeners and I'm you know I'm a
Catholic I believe I said would you just
take a moment dear friends and just say
a prayer for for Casey and and for the
de Santa's family and I I did it because
you know I saw the news and I thought
let's you know use this power of Prayer
about a month later I get a letter from
the office of the first lady of Florida
and it's her thanking me I've never
received anything I mean apart from
present sending me stuff which is fine
it's my old boss I've never received
something from a public figure of that
ilk to thank me for something
so so I'm not gonna qualify her
politically I will say one thing he does
need somebody to humanize him because he
he is not you know you've met him right
the guy is not warm and fuzzy I mean he
knows how to slam down the media and
it's beautiful to watch but he's not a
people person he's not a people person
so uh I appreciate that and and my
feeling about her is the same way
however I have a big however I'll be the
bad guy you can meet a nice guy so
and I haven't heard anything bad about
it but who wrote where was that piece
this is political oh but but it's but
it's also coming from uh a few others as
well I mean it's not it's not just that
that's talking about them Insider said a
few things which doesn't say much about
Insider but here's the part for me I
come from a different angle you ever
seen the movie Air the recent movie with
uh you're not a basketball guy so this
movie The Story of Michael Jordan how
Nike landed him Etc et cetera there's a
scene with son of a car you that's
preparing Michael Jordan for the fall to
say listen yes you're going to win
championships yes you're going to win
MVPs you're going to do all this stuff
great but guess what they're going to
come after you and for me there's
different types of wives meaning ivani
am I saying uh Melania is the kind of a
wife a first lady to me that's kind of
like listen I support you I'll go do the
shaking hands all this stuff but I'm not
going to be Michelle Obama it's you
makes sense like this is your job I got
Baron is my job and I'm going to be this
but do not get me involved and guess
what my view president Donald Trump
saying you're totally fine babe do what
you got to do I got this that's kind of
how I view that okay uh for me Barack uh
if you bring Michelle in and Michelle's
also throwing punches you gotta if we
get into a fight let's just say me and
my wife a woman comes and a husband and
wife are fighting us
if he's swinging and if my wife swings
her at her she swings back I'm not going
to be surprised that's what her job is
let's just say but if my wife is like
listen let's step aside let's have our
husbands kind of do their thing that's
what I see but Casey is a also a fighter
so but is she doing that fighting
publicly like Michelle I don't think no
I don't see her as Michelle at all I
don't see her as Michelle but I think
she's part of the campaign the whole
thing Casey and Ron DeSantis have such a
close partnership they've morphed into a
singular entity people called the de
santai right not the DeSantis political
there's a part of this that if you play
to this card I do believe they have to
be ready that people are going to come
after her because she is one of those oh
no they have they have to be ready so I
just want to make sure it's not going to
be like unfair what they're doing no
expect the darkest of the ways to
approach you yeah and to me uh if the
approach is kind of like it's unfair
what they're doing it's got to be more
totally get it if we're choosing to have
that highest job in office in America
this comes with the territory and we're
totally okay with that right that to me
is a little bit more of a you know
respect but I gotta tell you I've been a
lot of small group settings and I've
seen a lot of wives that are super
powered on a cup power couple power
she is very very solid and what I mean
by solid Charisma charm likability
incredible Communicator smart
intelligent True Believer mannerisms
respecting husband edifying him getting
out of the way not the shadow doesn't
need the Limelight doesn't even take the
the shots that Michelle would take out
Obama I don't know if you know what
shots I'm talking about sometimes she
kind of undermines him zero all of that
she's a she's a dime in the way of a
first lady so I think that is going to
be a big part for him you made a common
tour when you said you kind of got to be
out there more I don't know how much of
a role she's going to be playing I think
if she does play a role
um she's a she's a very strong uh uh
she's a very strong a strength of his if
it's used so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]